what up space fam golson here from anime
outpour back at it again to discuss the
latest and craziest developments in the
one piece story we got a bunch of
developments including developments
about the hype zoro vs king fight so
make sure to stay tuned for that if you
do enjoy seeing these one-piece reviews
and want to keep them coming channel
parking within and smash that like
button with no mercy remember smashing
that like button is pirate king energy
and passing is orochi energy so choose
wisely if you haven't make this the
video you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications so you don't miss future
one piece videos and updates and while
you wait for the next chapter to drop
feel free to check out my huge and
growing playlist that includes videos on
all the yonko admirals supernova and
much more link to that is in the
description now without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all the
chapter is called odin's beloved sword
so you can imagine that it will have a
zorro focus but more on that later the
chapter starts with marco in phoenix
forum carrying izo over the battlefield
marco complains saying it's a pain to
fly eazl around when he's injured but
izo says the giant yokai made him feel
uneasy so it seems like they want to
help deal with that too i don't know how
ezo could help at this point but marco's
special flame and or yamato's deity ice
powers may be able to do something we
shall see place your bets in the
comments on what and who will stop
kanjuro's flame yokai i can't see yamato
not playing a role since it's been her
self-imposed responsibility to keep the
weapons from exploding for several
chapters now i love the panel where
marco happens to fly by big mom where we
get a glimpse of her face which looks
like gluttony from fma right now that is
definitely fitting for her character she
looks a bit beat up but if anything she
looks like she's having a blast anyways
it's just a little reminder that that
other epic fight is still going on some
beast pirates fetch a cannon to help
make their way through the samurai so
they can escape burning alive and then
we jump back to yamato apu drake and the
number fuga who may or may not be zoro's
dad according to some theories fuga
represents the number two which could be
a nod to ushimaru's dual wielding style
and this number clearly knows and is
close to yamato just as ushimaru was in
the cave flashback and there's more
possible clues but i personally hope
this is not the case fuga definitely
doesn't have the cool vibe you'd want
from zorro's dad and that ushimaru used
to have we'll see let me know if you
lend any credence to this theory back to
the story and apoo drake and fuga are
all chasing yamato yamato even tells
fuga i know it's been a while but i'm in
a hurry so you can tell they are on good
terms here suddenly brooke and robin
joined the party landing on fuga's hair
cp 0 drops 2 chasing them but they get
caught in the flame yokai everyone is
shocked by this jokai and finally yamato
realizes that if it can go through walls
it'll get to the armory very soon and
set off the explosions while the island
is still in mid-air although she didn't
predict this happening in retrospect oda
sent her down to help stop it again
guardian deity ice wolf stops dangerous
flame yokai sounds very fitting
obviously fire tends to melt ice but ice
then becomes water which is super
effective against fire according to
pokemon at least and there's no telling
how yamato's special ice will mesh with
kanjuro's special fire after all her ice
powers did cancel out kaido's flame
breath blast lastly makami the
inspiration for yamato's fruit was a
guardian deity thought to protect humans
from misfortune including fire so yeah
yamato vs fire yokai confirmed that
being said there has to be a reason
marco and iso are coming too either way
hopefully we'll get a song of ice and
fire thing going on soon enough yamato
then asks for fuga's help while brooke
and robin watch the cp zero agents burn
obviously they are fine after all that
hype a country of creation is not gonna
take them down and the shorter go
playing one even attacks apu after apu
suggests giving morgans the scoop of how
after losing the middleman doflamingo
the government started to deal directly
with kaido the mention of morgan's is
always hype because we can only imagine
what he'll make of this war after the
fact the cp-0 agent closes the distance
in a split second and apoo looks badly
damaged but it's not the first time i
gotta hand it to apu the dude's
endurance is next level we get a little
conversation between drake and the agent
and it's said that 0 knows where his
true allegiance lies the agent goes to
attack implying he's a pest before apu
helps out with an attack of his own now
apu and drake are seemingly together
against cp 0 which is hilarious to see
because of how often you see up who's
switching his allies and enemies i'm not
even mad especially with this team up
and it's strange to see drake and cp 0
having so much beef i mentioned last
time that drake isn't really a regular
marine in the sense that he wanted to
specifically deal with apu for luffy
even though it made no sense for a
marine to think like that the sword
organization is still surrounded in
mystery but this suggests that kobe and
drake have their own goals separate from
the majority of marines now we see the
two previously feuding supernova
attacked the two agents again crazy how
much energy apu has left after
everything he's been through and let me
know what you think about this matchup
cp zero agents have been hyped up so
will they crush these two or will it be
a prolonged fight for me these guys
honestly don't have to be that strong i
don't really care i wouldn't even care
if apu and drake beat them but i know
some fans want these dudes to be
formidable so let me know there is one
more agent that's not here who robin and
brooke may have to deal with somehow but
those odds seem a lot better now than
when they had to deal with all three
then we jump to the most high part of
the chapter zoro vs king even though
king seemed like a very cool right hand
man to kaido he is not immune from oda's
dinosaur jokes in a not very cool
looking move king pulls his head back to
the point where it looks completely
unnatural he lets go like a slingshot
and zoro's surprised that he couldn't
block it since the attack is like a beam
like the dinocopter moment king says
that that's how tyrannodons hunted their
prey in prehistoric times that's just
been oda this arc confusing children
everywhere about how dinosaurs actually
work and of course zoro seemingly as
clueless as ever asks is that so if
anyone would believe it it's probably
zorro and luffy for that matter zoro
though is not in good shape here panting
and having trouble reaching the airborne
king in this case he's just wasting
energy with his attacks as king dodges
them he desperately needs a power up
here just like sanji got sora starts
asking questions that don't sound any
crazier than what king is saying like
that tyrannodons flew with fire on their
backs too but king says no that of
course seems to be part of his lunarian
genes as has been suggested zoro notices
that king is talking down to him and
decides he needs to knock him out of the
sky his great dragon twister is easily
blocked by king using his wings after
this zorro says that dinosaurs are a lot
like dragons king says he's not wrong
but king himself is on another level
that's a pretty arrogant thing to say
when someone compares your powers to
like the strongest creature ever but
king is backing it up here king even
takes pity on zorro and says he'll give
him a chance by using his sword instead
he's been craving a good duel as well
and here you really feel the talking
down that zoro mentioned king truly
feels like he's on another level
compared to zorro and that is the way
the fight's been going so far as zoro
mentions after all of zoro's attacks
king hasn't spilled even a drop of blood
zorro is analyzing king's human form and
how he still has wings here and the
flames are burning so these aren't
features of his fruit powers like zoro
thought at first he thinks maybe he has
fishman or giant blood but then decides
that it must be a race he's never heard
of and king launches him back leaving
him in a lot of pain zorro thinks to
himself i don't think i can win which is
crazy to hear but then you move down and
he says without knowing what he is so
there is still a path to victory for
zorro but he needs to find out more
about king that to me is a bit strange
why would it matter if he learns the
exact race unless they have a specific
weakness but zoro seems pretty sure
about it let me know your thoughts about
this in the comments how could the
knowledge of king being a lunarian for
example actually change the tide as much
as zoro is expecting i love the just
cuts down whatever is in front of him
without asking questions zorro but i
guess we can't blame him for wanting or
needing to strategize in this case then
ashami sen the musical instrument is
heard and mud the sword starts reacting
as zorro seems to be all but beaten and
there's a giant explosion of flames and
probably hockey surrounding the sword it
is odin's sword the one that even heard
kaido and gave him scars it has to be
strong enough to beat king but it's just
a matter of zorro bringing out enough of
its power and here is where zoro's
needed upgrade and power up is coming in
the sword will take him to the next
level it'll bring out more from him and
he'll bring out more from it it's not as
cheap as it might seem at first glance
because it's already been stated that
most people would not be able to wield
enma and would be drained of all their
hockey so it zorro's hard work and
mastery that will be able to unlock the
potential of enema and take him to the
next level an interesting question too
is whether he'll be able to call upon
haki that enema absorbed before this
would explain why it gave off an odin
vibe to kaido and perhaps zoro will be
able to use that stored haki to increase
his own power as well the fact that the
sword responded to hiyori playing the
shamisen seems to support this
possibility there are a lot of
possibilities here but it's clear right
now to me that this sword will be the
key for zorro getting the upgrade he
needs to beat king and it's already
begun the chapter ends off with orochi
seeing hiri who he's still completely
crazy about he even says if he's
dreaming he doesn't want to wake up so
you definitely can't deny his feelings
here although he doesn't know that
komurasaki is actually hiyori the
daughter of odin hiyori or at least what
looks like hiyori says all that she
wants is to spend the rest of her life
with orochi this seems from her
perspective like she's going to take him
out and herself in the process but we'll
see it'll be interesting to also see how
orochi responds to the fact that the
woman he clearly is so crazy about is
actually the daughter of his greatest
enemy whom he executed but that is it
for this chapter definitely more so uh
setting things up chapters and crazy
actions taking place chapter but still
very enjoyable let me know what you
thought of it and what you're looking
forward to most in the next one who was
your mvp i gotta go with zorro in this
one yeah he's been losing against king
but he's been hustling not giving up and
is about to turn the tide if you did
enjoy this review and want to keep them
coming you know what to do channel the
piraking within and smash that like
button with no mercy remember smashing
that like button is pirate king energy
and passing is orochi energy so choose
wisely if you haven't make this the
video you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications so you don't miss future
one piece videos and updates and while
you wait for the next chapter to drop
feel free to check out my huge and
growing playlist that includes videos on
all yonko admiral supernova and much
more link to that one piece playlist is
in the description and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you